Why are some languages
more difficult than others?
It's a subject that comes up all the time.
I want to talk about that today, and
then I'm going to introduce you to a
very interesting person, where we
discuss the subject in greater detail.
I think there are six or seven
major reasons why we find learning
languages difficult, and some
more difficult than others.
The first reason, I think, and one
of the biggest reasons, is that we
put too much pressure on ourselves.
It's difficult to learn a language.
In other words, it's more
difficult than speaking your
own language.
When you speak your own language,
there is no pressure, and even
there you have a much larger passive
vocabulary than active vocabulary.
Point number two then is the
more different the language
is from your own language, the
more difficult it's going to be.
Obviously a different writing system or
similar vocabulary, similar structure.
One example, which I'll show you,
is when I go to do Dutch, it's
very easy for me because it's
written in the Latin alphabet.
It has a lot of
common vocabulary with languages that
I already speak. So it's a breeze.
Let's take the example of Dutch.
I decided to play around a bit with Dutch.
I hadn't been studying Dutch.
I went in there [in LingQ] and I did the first
five lessons in Sentence View, and
I just breezed through it in no
time, even though the Dutch shows
me that there are 79% new words.
In fact, the language is so
similar to languages that I know
that I can go through it in
Sentence View, understand it, and
pretty soon I'm getting a flavor of
Dutch and I feel I'm getting somewhere.
If I go now to Arabic, for the same
percentage of unknown words, even
this, it says 12% unknown words, I know
it's gonna be super difficult for me.
It's not just the new words, it's
also how similar the language is to
a language that you already know.
The third reason is I think people
take on too much at one time.
That's why we have Sentence Mode at LingQ.
You know, reduce the amount of strange
new words that you are looking at.
Help yourself as much as possible.
Listen to it, make it less strange.
Take it in smaller bites.
A fourth reason is that certain
languages have sort of quirks.
It might be the spelling
system in English, or even
in French, or even in Greek.
Or it might be gender, or it might be the
case system in German or Slavic languages.
So these particular quirks can make some
languages more difficult than others.
The fifth reason is the availability
of interesting content.
I think when we start, we have a
high tolerance for kind of repetitive
and somewhat boring material, but
we have to then get onto things of
interest and some languages just have
more availability, like English, like
Spanish, like Russian, of that kind
of interesting content at our level.
Another big factor is
your inherent motivation.
So a language may be difficult.
Intrinsically, for all the reasons that
I've pointed out, it's more different.
It has these quirks, call it.
There's a lack of resources.
But if you're tremendously
motivated, you can overcome those.
So let's make that just sort of a
brief introduction to this subject.
And now I want you to
meet Zoe of Zoe Languages.
And we discussed this in
greater detail. So it's very
appropriate that you are from China.
So many people consider
Chinese to be very difficult.
I was recently in Poland, the
Polls consider their language
to be very difficult.
The Koreans say their language
is the most difficult.
I'm having trouble with Arabic right now.
I know that you speak Persian
and Arabic, and of course you're
a native speaker of Chinese.
From your perspective, what is the
most difficult language to learn?
Okay.
Firstly, I want to thank you.
I want to say that I was inspired by you.
I've been watching a lot of your
videos, and after learning Arabic, I've
decided to learn Turkish and Persian.
Because of you!
Because you have inspired me.
Wow.
I want to say thank you.
Yeah.
Do you know that FSI Ranking
Foreign Service Institute?
Exactly.
This famous ranking is
geared towards English
speakers.
Mm-hmm.
It varies depending on your mother tongue.
Some people will still insist there's no
such thing as the most difficult language.
Right.
They argue it's Russian or it's is Greek.
I think you have more experience than me.
Also, some people even say English,
as they have been learning it for so
long, but still can't speak it. And
their points are not entirely off-base.
For example, I speak seven languages.
I can't count Mandarin because
it's my native language.
I think the most difficult
foreign language for me is
Arabic. It's my number one.
I've been
struggling.
Can you give us a list of
the languages that you speak?
I'll give you the
list.
According to the difficulty.
The first one, number one is Arabic.
My native language is Mandarin,
right, and the most difficult
language I've ever learned is Arabic.
The second one is German.
The third one is Turkish.
The fourth one is French,
and then the next is Persian.
The last one is English.
Okay.
But this list isn't objective at all.
It's completely relative, and based on
my personal learning journey. When we
talk about difficulty, we can have
difficulty in speaking correctly.
In other words, complicated grammar.
We can have difficulty in
pronunciation. We can have difficulty
in comprehension so that the aspects
of the language that are difficult
can vary from language to language.
Would you agree?
Totally agree.
But I prefer to say that it's easy
to define the difficulty of learning
the basics of a language.
It's straightforward to identify how
hard the pronunciation is, for example,
like the four tones in Mandarin,
Chinese, and or the writing system
and how complex the grammar rules are.
Because, for example, Arabic, because of
the gender, and a lot of other grammatical
rules like German. Chinese tones
and writings are very, very difficult.
But these kind of things
can be learned in practice.
But in my opinion, once we reach
an upper-intermediate level, all
languages become equally challenging
because the difficulty lies elsewhere.
It's in the immersion environment.
Your knowledge of the
culture and society and so on.
Here, I would like to give an example.
In my opinion, Persian
would be easier than Arabic.
In terms of the grammar in
Arabic, there are complex gender,
plural, and conjugation rules.
However, when I travel to Iran
and communicate with locals,
I find it easy to have a basic
conversation, to express myself.
I learned very quickly at the beginner
level until the intermediate level.
I already have a lot of vocabulary
because I knew Arabic already
and the grammar is easier than Arabic.
But while I was in Iran, sometimes I
can even discuss complex
topics because we have the context.
Of the conversation we are interacting.
People are aware that I'm a
foreigner, so they speak slower.
Use simple vocabulary and
clear sentence structure
to help me understand better.
However, it is still extremely challenging
for me to follow my Iranian friends'
conversations.
They speak quickly and use a
lot of colloquial expressions.
So understanding them requires
knowledge of culture and the social
context.
I certainly do agree with you that
Persian is easier than Arabic.
I wouldn't have put German
as such a difficult language,
but that's your experience.
Someone who's native language
is English, maybe has an easier
time with German. I don't know.
But another aspect of difficulty
is how easy it is to find good
learning content.
Interesting learning content.
Yeah, so, generally speaking, it's
becoming easier to find good learning
content nowadays via the internet.
I was just, before our discussion,
I went to MTV Lebanon and I got
an MP3 file from there, and
I can import that into LingQ and
it automatically transcribes it.
And so I have a lesson that
wouldn't have been possible
even a few years ago. [For] Persian,
it's more difficult to find good
learning content. In some languages,
there's just an abundance of
good audio and text learning content.
Yeah.
So that's another factor
that affects difficulty.
Yeah.
Agree.
That's why I think it's not really fair
to put English at the end of my list.
We already learn English at school.
Mm-hmm.
And these days, we expose
ourselves to English content.
As you said, it's easy to
find immersion environments.
Which make our studies seem easier
compared to languages that lack learning
resources such as Persian or Turkish.
So I personally don't find English
difficult, not surprisingly, but
it also depends. You know, some
people say, "Well, English is easy!"
It is easier because
of the environment.
So many people speak English,
whether they're native speakers
or not native speakers.
Yeah.
Now then the question is, how well
do you want to speak this language?
There are people, for example, who say
that French is hard to understand because
of the liaison, because it's hard to hear
the clear sort of definition of where
one word ends and the next word begins.
Japanese is somehow
difficult because of the way
the Japanese people communicate.
There's a lot of things that are not
said that are kind of understood.
So I think every language
comes with its difficulty.
To me, the biggest issue is motivation.
If you're very motivated,
difficulties fade away.
Agree.
I have a question for you, actually.
Yeah.
You know 20
languages, right?
Not always up to the level I'd like,
but experience learning 20 languages.
Yes.
I'm curious
about your ranking, the difficulty
ranking of these languages.
Well,
right now I would put Arabic at the top.
If I say, okay, Chinese, the
difficulty there is the characters.
There's... that's just a matter of time.
You have to put in so much time
because, you know, the sooner you learn a
character than you forget it. And
you gotta learn it again and again.
And so that takes a lot of time.
On the other hand, when I was learning
Chinese, it was my full-time job, so
I was doing it six, seven hours a day.
So within a year I was
reading books in Chinese.
The grammar in Chinese is extremely easy.
It's probably the easiest grammar
of any language I've ever learned.
Nothing changes.
There's no gender, there's no conjugation.
There's some patterns of how the
language works, and you get used
to those patterns and away you go.
So Arabic certainly is
up there in difficulty.
I think the Slavic languages are
difficult because of a very complicated
grammar, so many different changes to
words, depending on their function
Mm-hmm.
in a sentence. I never consider
pronunciation a big issue.
If I pronounce it well or less
well, it's good enough.
You know, I don't worry about that.
But it's hard to speak the
Slavic languages accurately,
in other words, correctly.
Mm-hmm.
In Chinese, it's hard to make a
mistake, assuming you have the word.
And of course, another advantage
in Chinese is if you get the
characters, you can easily build your
vocabulary because so many of what we
would call words in English are in
fact the combination of characters.
So the more characters you
have, the more new words you can
learn or recognize or guess at.
No, I would say that the difficulty right now
is Arabic for sure. Agree.
And that's about it.
The easiest to learn is any
extension of a language you
know; another romance language.
Another Slavic language. Korean
I found difficult because of a lack
of interesting content with audio
and text that I could study on LingQ.
See, I'm not so interested
in series on Netflix.
K-Drama or K-Pop.
No, not that doesn't interest me.
But to those people who are
interested in that, then there's a
wealth of material for learning Korean.
Yeah.
So.
It's very subjective, but I'm very
impressed that you have reached
out to learn languages of different
language groups, and I think it's
an exciting thing to do to explore
different parts of the world.
Now you're exploring the Middle
East, which I'm also trying to do.
I was inspired by you!
Let's hope that we inspire people who
are watching this to not spend too much
time worrying about the difficulty, be
motivated by their interests, whether it
be history and geography, as is our case.
Or anime for Japanese or K-pop
for Korean or whatever it might
be for Chinese or other languages,
and go out and explore the world.
It's a wonderful thing to do.
Yeah.
Well listen, thank you very much.
Thank you.
And you are @Zoe.Languages on YouTube
and people can go there and watch you
explore these different languages.
I saw your videos when you were in
Iran, conversing with the people there
in the shops or with your friends.
A wonderful example for us to follow.
Thank you for joining me.
Thank you.
Thank you, Steve.